welcome to this video and playing taos
ski from from Finland oops not h6
playing some relatively low rated
opponent see at the moment maybe it's a
good thing I'm not in the best of shapes
and really whenever I've when I'm below
2300 I really feel like you're
something's terribly off I really need
to step up my game a bit to get back to
the higher 2300 sisters relief what what
seems appropriate ok he took on d5
question is I can just recapture or I
can take on d4 which is also possible ok
now this is ok cd5 is probably not the
most testing continuation yeah he really
really wants to exchange pieces who came
how to continue its not a big problem
here the team wants to take on g7 the
question is some Queen a five yeah I
should I take first or queen a from
Queen a5 immediately he hmm yeah I don't
really know but I'd like to quickly get
some play going against the sea porn
the question is should i take maybe even
takes Knight eggs does this speed up my
plane not sure not sure we have now
we're thinking 97 but he's got night see
form okay okay well not c4 I have Queen
a form everything else fails or maybe
just Quincy something not sure okay this
I don't know maybe yeah well maybe it's
not a big deal and he can can do that
tending 94 for Bishop d3 sm easy reply
so let's see
how to how to set up the pieces the
bishop is er is that's an open question
where to put it
I can go to e6 on I can go for B 6b 6b
basics yeah i'm not sure i'm absolutely
not sure but i spent ages being not sure
down to two minutes something okay 95 is
it a month I was ever speed up a bit
yeah baby he's got 95 now yeah the this
i didn't i didn't really fear me I
thought that I maybe have some some some
claim against the polls not that I'm not
saying black as barrister trying to
generate some imbalance well now this he
can play of course okay this is probably
not the best move but as mentioned I'd
like to have some imbalance
okay yeah 9065 I'd like to provoke d5
here so that my night regains a good
square on c5 maybe I should try to
increase pressure against the deep on
like rook tha look the eighth night f3
Bishop g4 something like that at least
is taking some time that's a bit strange
this move going from 93 in order to
protect e5 or does he want to i'm not
sure what this move is doing maybe i'm
preparing the king okay i'm going back
all the way because be 695 bishop a6
might be my dear set up yeah should I go
night see 5 or what about f5 now you
came
I can go to see three actually to
threaten I'd be five yeah I know f five
weekends here on the EVO II 697 but I
thought is it not is not in the position
to exploit it and i have e 6 now for
example okay prove here and now try to
break up the center yes that's nice and
how he cannot go to d3 and like has got
the better structure now yeah i have to
default and dirty for maybe rookie for
attacking him
yeah and I don't want to take on c4 at
the moon he will activate his rope on
the seventh row just King f6 improving
makes more sense should I take it now
yeah it's got 95 at the end not helping
ok let's try to get rid of the snide
check ok no it's up its passive now f4
on before him yeah before he goes back
to you three
check i am i'm slowly making some
progress but this takes away d 3 and c 2
he doesn't have many moves ok can deform
maybe 92 yeah the position is excellent
the clock is not
check yeah this probably wasn't check
the best way to play I'm warning but I
don't have any time
attacking the week pawn difficult to
keep it check check check check check
check check check check check check
check stalemate maybe I could have one
on time I don't know ah what the heck
yeah very little very little time left
of course check this is probably not so
clever I mean it's it's it's it's
winning like every move but it's a this
this this is allowing the draw with this
perpetual rook yeah well I've got seven
seconds let's say it's tricky it's
tricky yeah this is why I'm not rate
high rated at the modem losing points in
this kind of silly games well I'm I'm
simply simply winning and don't manage
due to time or my own stupid stupidity
here I really shouldn't allow any couple
to play but it's not not easy with
little time here for example just just
to show what you can do if you have some
time your bishop see to this is
completely killing the rook it has no
square whatsoever and I'm just taking
here with the bishop
it's just completely dead this position
no counter play whatsoever yeah what can
you do Eddie to get into better blitz
shape so that I don't let those points
slip that that often alright thanks for
watching